ministre la parole et à monsieur gilles
lurton merci monsieur le président saint
malo ville hautement fréquenté en cette
période de vacances saint malo et
bloqués depuis plus de 24 heures
savez vous pourquoi monsieur le premier
ministre face à un immense sentiment de
mépris de votre gouvernement face au
dédain du ministre de votre ministre de
l'agriculture les agriculteurs sont
aujourd'hui dans la rue je les ai
rencontrés hier à saint-malo leurs
questions sont simples ils veulent vivre
de leur travail
pourquoi leurs produits sont ils vendus
moins cher que ce qu'il leur coûte entre
le prix d'achat et celui de vente au
consommateur que se passe-t-il où passe
l'argent à ces questions vous ne
répondez pas monsieur le premier
ministre vous dénoncez les conséquences
de la loi de modernisation de l'économie
mais qu'avez vous fait depuis trois ans
quels sont les résultats de la loi
d'avenir sur l'agriculture ou plutôt
l'absence de résultats
qu'avez-vous fait au niveau européen
pour reconquérir les marchés extérieurs
et redonner de la compétitivité à notre
agriculture
après autant de les intérêts et de
désinvolture alors que la maison brûle
vous annoncer aujourd'hui 24 mesures
pour éteindre le feu
des mesures financières d'urgence certes
mais que valent mille euros alors qu'une
exploitation laitière en perd quatre
mille tous les mois des mesures
financières certes mais quelles mesures
structurelles pour l'avenir
vous ne fait que reporter les charges
qu'en sera-t-il à l'automne où sont les
mesures de simplification des normes
tant promise alors que vous les avez
complexifier à outrance depuis trois ans
monsieur le premier ministre
avec mes collègues bretons isabelle le
callennec thierry benoît marc le fur et
philippe le ray nous n'avons cessé de
vous alerter sur les particularités des
éleveurs et agriculteurs bretons comme
eux nous attendons toujours une réponse
la parole est à monsieur stéphane le
foll mais les agricultures de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt ce
président est monsieur le député je ne
veux pas d'ailleurs cherché à répondre
à la manière dont vous avez posez votre
question on a signé en plus que j'aurai
du dédain pour les agriculteurs parce
que franchement monsieur le député
sillonna camp du dédain je ferais
remarquer que certains alors qu'on parle
d'agriculture cet après midi sont déjà
partis qu'après avoir posé une question
ou 7 exprimé dans les médias ne sont pas
à l'assemblée nationale pour discuter
des sujets de fond
donc monsieur le député sur ce sujet
j'aimerais qu'on arrête ce genre de
formules parce que je n'ai jamais eu
mois de dédain pour les agriculteurs au
contraire je les ai toujours considéré
écouté et j'ai eu la proximité qui m'a
permis à chaque fois d'être respectés et
écoutés dans chacun de mes déplacements
monsieur le député sur ce sujet évitons
ce genre de formules la deuxième sur la
bretagne et j'ai vu que monsieur le fur
avait signé avec vous mais franchement
sur les questions environnementales sur
les questions de simplification rien
n'avait été fait jusqu'à ce que nous
arrivions mais quand je dis rien c'est
rien il ya eu la mise en place a été
rappelé par le premier ministre delà de
la procédure d'enregistrement qui
simplifie aujourd'hui toutes les
procédures en vue de mise en route de
projets en particulier dans le domaine
pour ça ce que vous aviez été incapable
même de proposer ou d'évoquer lorsque
vous étiez au gouvernement je
rappellerai aussi que dans le débat que
nous avons vu sur le contentieux sur les
zones vulnérables avec l'europe
aujourd'hui pour la première fois sur
neuf bassins contentieux qui était en
contentieux depuis plus de dix ans cinq
sont sortis du contentieux
aujourd'hui grâce à l'action que nous
avons menée donc monsieur le député
quand vous posez une question comme on
dit en normandie quand on monte au
premier il faut avoir une échelle pour
redescendre parce que vu ce que vous
avez fait vous verriez vous devriez
avoir un peu plus de retenue
en posant vos questions merci monsieur
le ministre